before Buffy Summers and Indiana Jones
before Superman and Ellen Ripley before
Robin Hood King Arthur and bolf or Ray
Skywalker Achilles and Katniss everine
there was the original Heroes journey
and quite possibly the oldest known
Story Ever Told The Epic of Gilgamesh
written around 5,000 years ago in what
is now Iraq the Mesopotamian myth of
Gilgamesh has become the gold standard
against which folkloric Heroes Have Been
measured and his story contains many of
the foundational tropes of Mythology
even if you've never read a Gilgamesh
Legend his battles with monsters
squabbles with Gods Journeys to other
worlds and general agonizing about what
it means to be a hero will probably look
familiar but these storytelling devices
were cutting edge at the time and copied
over and over again even though these
narrative beats hail from a time that
feels so unlike our own gilgamesh's
inner Journey still feels relevant today
when we look closely at his errors his
relationships and his character
transformation
it's clear that he's so much more than a
mythical
[Music]
blueprint we first meet Gilgamesh as the
beautiful brutal leader of the Sumerian
city of UK he's kind of a toxic bro who
likes getting into brawls and seducing
Brides on their wedding nights the
goddess aruru finally gets sick of Gil's
Antics and mixes up some spit and Clay
to create a powerful adversary for him
Harry Wildman oh I'm sorry I read that
wrong I mean a hairy wild man named in
kidu sometimes depicted as half bull
half man with superhuman strength but an
innocent heart like grank in kidu skulks
outside the city walls eating grass and
befriending animals before striding into
the city to challenge Gilgamesh to a
fight the two appear to be evenly
matched as they wrestle across the city
until Gilgamesh eventually triumphs
after duking it out their rival returns
to mutual
respect
you're good Gilgamesh I'll give you that
you too and K do the TRU sure you know
maybe we should like join up forces we'd
probably be better together oh I love
that you know I've always wanted a
sidekick oh great wait
what despite their differences from that
day onwards the two are inseparable wait
that reminds me of
something
in kidu's innocence and communion with
nature make him a foil for gilgamesh's
excessive Tendencies but their
relationship is more intimate than your
run-of-the-mill hero sidekick Dynamic
you could call it the original Bromance
but many have viewed Gilgamesh and enidu
as a homoerotic or queer love story in
which the two provide each other with
much needed companionship and Care their
relationship is described as a marriage
in numerous passages of the Epic and
it's the first time we see Gilgamesh
caring about someone other than himself
Gilgamesh even confides his deepest
desire to his new companion to achieve
lasting Fame this was a lot harder to do
before YouTube so together they embark
on a series of rebellious escapades
chopping down a sacred Cedar Forest
murdering the many-headed guardian of
the Cedars and killing the sacred bull
of Heaven God forbid he should try to
get famous by I don't know planting a
cedar forest or healing a sacred bull
well the gods didn't like it either as
punishment they strike enidu with a
terminal illness and he dies in
gilgamesh's arms wait what enidu was the
nice one all this chopping and killing
for fame was gilgamesh's idea but
enkidu's death provides an opportunity
for Gilgamesh to grow how nice for
Gilgamesh he realizes he's been going
about things all wrong his goal
shouldn't be Fame but immortality aim
high I guess Gilgamesh wanders across
the Wilderness in search of utnapishtim
a wise man who had been granted
immortality by the gods as a reward for
saving Humanity from a cataclysmic flood
by building a giant Ark what does that
remind me of dualan no uh Vias no uh
burir no um forget it to find
utnapishtim Gilgamesh must pass through
masu a mountain rooted in the Underworld
and towering towards heaven its
Guardians a pair of Scorpion Warriors
warn him that no light touches The
Passage through mashu after hours of
total darkness and Howling winds
Gilgamesh emerges into a glittering
Garden Beyond The Garden lies the Sea of
death and there on the shore is a bar
but instead of Tom Cruz in a Hawaiian
shirt this bar is tended by the Divine
Alewife siduri like any good bartender
siduri listens to gilgamesh's woes and
gives him some smart advice quit this
wild goose chase and just enjoy what's
left of your short mortal life does that
sound like something AR Gilgamesh would
do heck no he ignores her and sails to
utnapishtim's Island where he begs the
old man for the secret to immortality
utap pisum also thinks Gil's mission is
boneheaded but like a Divine reality
show host offers him a couple physical
challenges first if he can stay awake
for 7 days straight the gods might Grant
him immortality that's it this is the
guy who chopped down the sacred Cedars
and hunted the bull of Heaven staying
awake should be no problem at oh oh yeah
he falls asleep
next he must Reeve a magical youth
giving plant from the bottom of the
ocean which gets snatched right out of
his hands by a snake dejected and
defeated Gilgamesh finally gives up on
his dreams and heads home but there a
profound character shift occurs the
specifics vary depending on which
version you're reading maybe he settles
down and starts a family maybe he
focuses on being a good leader and City
Builder or maybe he pursues wisdom and
writes about his adventures whatever the
details Gilgamesh comes to accept his
human limitations and like the gods had
been pushing him to do all along make
the most of his limited time on Earth
this is still a massively popular
narrative device how many Heroes set off
in Pursuit Of Fame and riches only to
learn that the real treasure is the
friends we made along the way Gilgamesh
set the standard for real heroes knowing
when to give up on Fame and glory and
just let it go gilgamesh's decision to
write about his life is also a popular
hero Trope with particular meaning for
the Sumer people gilgamesh's domain oruk
was a real place that grew into a vast
urban center during the fourth
millennium BCE and is considered by many
to be the world's first real City
bureaucracy and finance increase the
demand for writers who kept records and
track resources but also put oral
stories to tablet written in CA form the
oldest known form of writing the Epic of
Gilgamesh is one of the earliest works
of literature that testifies in numerous
ways to the enduring human desire to
make oury Mark in that way Gilgamesh did
kind of achieve immortality maybe
instead of sending him to the Bottom of
the Sea UT nistam should have just
handed him a chisel and tablet and sent
him home now it's time for another one
of our Pantheon picks this is something
new we're doing this season Dr Z and I
are each going to choose different
figures from mythology that we love and
we're going to join them in a United
Pantheon at the end of this season I
made my first pick in the first episode
of the season and now it is Dr Z's turn
for a Mesopotamian mythology episode and
probably the least surprising pick of
all time I'm going with tiam what I know
shocking from the monster expert uh
Tiamat is considered a mother by some
people now but she was a creation deity
originally she literally housed all of
Creation in Mesopotamian mythology in
her womb and I think like a warm squishy
water bed of creation sounds like a nice
option to have to relax in the Utopia
she can create life and also could help
us defending the Utopia against anyone
trying to attack us if we need to make
some kind of weird Pegasus weather demon
hybrid she's got the experience oh
brilliant choice I love that and you're
right I'm not surprised but your
justification is perfect Immaculate
great choice thank
[Music]
you before you go PBS has several new
documentary series over on PBS voices
and if you haven't seen them Now's the
Time ritual explores the history of
unique customs from across the American
South dead and buried reexamines our
society's relationship with death and
brave spaces spotlights lgbtq
communities standing strong in the face
of adversity we've got links in the
description we hope you check them out
and let us know what you
think Sor
right start from the top Let It
Go I mean even though you
wut